secretary as Deputy Prime Minister
because he had promised that he would
stand down if the complaints of bullying
against him were upheld that appears to
be be what has happened in this inquiry
from Adam's Holly but Dominic Robb also
taking issue with how that those reports
were upheld and how actually this
investigation has progressed so the now
former Justice secretary clearly not
happy with how this inquiry has
progressed going through the rest of the
letter uh Dominic Raab says that
ministers must be able to exercise
direct oversight with respect to senior
officials over critical negotiations
conducted on behalf of the British
people otherwise the Democratic and
constitutional principle of Minister
responsibility will be lost he talks
about ministers being able to give
direct critical feedback on briefings
and submissions to senior officials to
set standards and drive reform and says
that Mr Tully Adams Holly the barrister
that carried out this inquiry concluded
that Dominic Robb had not once in four
and a half years sworn or shaved at
anyone let alone thrown anything or
otherwise physically intimidated anyone
so
essentially the Top Line being and we
don't yet know whether this has happened
as a result of a conversation with Rishi
sunak it may well be that Rishi sunak uh
almost pushed Dominic Raab into this
decision what tends to happen as a
matter of protocol is rather than
someone necessarily just being sacked
without any notice they can be given the
opportunity to resign although what
dominic Robb is saying in this letter is
actually he feels Duty bound to stick to
what he previously promised and because
those complaints
were essentially upheld in this report
which remember we still haven't seen he
says as a result of that he will be
stepping down